i'm here with dating coach and life game
changer demona hoffman we're also here
with two single ladies looking for love
in the digital space and when we say two
ladies i think we mean
so many people on this planet and before
the break amy gave us the scoop on what
digital dating is like in your 40s and
now it's time to hear from allison who's
repping representing daters in their 20s
alison what is it like for you
dating is really confusing in your 20s i
have friends who are engaged and i also
have friends who are at the bars till 4
a.m and i feel like i do not know where
i kind of
settle into that mix i'm really looking
for a relationship i really want to be
in love i'm a romantic i'm a cancer if
you guys are into zodiac signs at all so
i really am craving that but i feel like
everyone that i'm kind of matching with
is kind of looking for one thing if you
catch my drift and it's not something
that i'm really interested in so i'm
kind of having a hard time with that
demona i love the spectrum friends out
till 4am other friends engaged what does
she ask herself to find where her needle
lands well she has to figure out what's
comfortable for her
and i would say allison you need to also
do a little work around
who you're looking for figuring out
what that what that perfect person would
be and maybe where that perfect person
might be hiding i think dating apps
should always be a part of your dating
portfolio and it's just the best way to
expand your dating pool but that doesn't
mean that you couldn't find love out at
a bar until 4 a.m doesn't happen often
doesn't mean it couldn't happen for you
though what is your approach with your
communication in online dating so i'm
super passive i kind of just wait for
the guy to take the lead i want to see
like where they're going to take it are
you gonna text me at 4 am saying you up
or are you gonna text me good morning
and be like i hope you have a great day
so i kind of just let them take the lead
i'm super picky about how i let men kind
of talk to me so sometimes i can come
across as that i'm not interested or a
little bit mean but i do try to let them
just take the lead and kind of fall back
a little bit okay so allison brought
some screenshots of her online messages
and dating profile for damona to weigh
in on to see
what demona's thoughts are because
that's what i live for
all right allison are you up for a
little role play with me let's do it
let's read your text message and
actually talk about what you said you um
i'll be the guy
and i'll be me and you i'll be right
okay perfect so he said
hey i'm gonna do my best guy voice okay
hey just seeing your roommate uh we
won't mark them down for bad grammar
what are you up to tonight
i'll be me oh i was sleeping
i don't do bars what a good girl you are
huh
when i saw her i was hoping to see you
okay what do you think you're giving off
with that text message it definitely
does seem like passive aggressive and
that i'm not interested so yes
absolutely about that i would like to
see you be a little bit more fun a
little bit more flirty and a little
engaging there was something you said
earlier that kind of concerned me you
said you were picky about how they
responded to you so when i hear picky i
actually think two things i think
lack of clarity on what you want what
you're looking for or fear right and
sometimes it's fear of rejection it's
fear of you know seeing your friends
partner up and feeling fearing you're
gonna be the last one left and it's
easier to say i'm picky than to say i'm
afraid that's fair you have to be able
to flirt now over text right and bring
that confidence the next time i want you
to turn up the heat a little bit i love
that thank you um
do you think you have fear i definitely
think i have fear i know i'm only 24 but
i've definitely dealt with a lot of
heart heartache in my
um dating life and also in my personal
life my mom actually just passed away in
june so that was definitely like a
personal heartache that i'm dealing with
and i feel like when you're grieving
especially like going through dating
it's kind of a little bit tricky because
you don't want to get hurt again you're
already healing something separately and
it's like i don't necessarily want to
get hurt in this realm of my life so i
definitely feel like i'm a little bit
fearful for sure paul i'm i'm so sorry
thank you thank you i really am
and um
when we are going through something how
do we communicate that in the romantic
world
well we have different seasons in our
life so this might not be the right
season for dating for allison right now
but in terms of when you're
communicating with dates
i like to think of it as people need to
earn information from you
and so your story is not everybody's
business so you know that's a very
personal thing that you shared that
might be something that you wouldn't
reveal on a first date but only when you
trust someone and know that they can
hold your feelings and and hold what you
tell them in confidence as well um and
listen you're in marketing right yes i
work in pr yeah well
you better start doing some pr for
yourself to market myself you're right
drew yeah and you are a content writer
yes well then
you should be
writing your very best right
apps that are true to you but if you're
a writer for a living i know you got the
goods
i do yeah no i can totally write a
profile
maybe we can get together and we can
help each other without yeah i can
market you you could write me a love
story done and done done and done
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you amy and alison and as
always
jamona
you
contextualize
what we are really navigating in life
and every time we talk i'm a smarter
wiser person thank you
[Music]
you